bonsoir crise merci d'être avec nous
anthony blinken inquiets beaucoup pointé
du doigt évidemment c'est le jeu la
responsabilité de l'administration trump
dans l'échec du départ américains hier
c'est donald trump acquis à rejeter la
responsabilité sur bayonne on semble
donc personne évidemment envie de porter
le chapeau mais finalement qui croire
dans cette histoire qui croire
évidemment il ya le jeu partisan donc on
s'attendait pas à ce que mme hayden
disent oui c'est de ma faute excusez moi
devant le peuple américain au contraire
c'est vrai d'abord que c'est tron qui
est initié ce retrait mais ce retrait
les initiés dès l'époque obama est
d'abord obtenu à l'époque obama ya eu un
seul c'est à dire plus de soldats avec
obama a vu que cette stratégie ne
marchait pas rne il a commencé
progressivement réduire le nombre de
soldats et a préféré préparer un plan
qui mettrait fin à cette guerre donc ça
date d'avant l'administration troll
trump lui aussi a pris les devants en
2018 il retire 7000 soldats c'est
d'ailleurs à ce moment là que les
talibans constate que mathématiquement
sur le terrain ils peuvent reprendre
l'initiative et avoir le dessus donc les
talibans commence à grignoter le pays à
partir de 2018 à partir de place forte
dans les campagnes donc finalement ce
qu'on se rend compte c'est que voilà le
l'administration 30 donne le feu vert
fait les accords avec les talibans
février 2020 donc accord de paix entre
l'armée américaine et le et le
les émissaires talibans de doha contre
l'avis du gouvernement afghan ça c'est
une donne factuel mais et donc c'est joe
biden qui lui va décider du retrait en
fait qui va respecter ce calendrier mais
le problème principal qui incombe à
l'administration byden et sur lequel
anthony blinken a énormément de mal à
s'exprimer c'est le manque de
planification de ce retrait on sait que
par exemple les français dès le mois de
mai sur la perte se avait avait pris
l'initiative de commencer à envisager le
rapatriement de leur traducteur d'un
certain nombre de gens ayant servi
l'armée française sachant qu'ils étaient
à risque tandis que la mère l armée
américaine et beaucoup d'autres nations
d'ailleurs les canadiens en particulier
n'avait toujours pas évolué sur ce sur
ce plan tout en sachant que de toute
façon à un moment ou à un autre
l'armée américaine allait se retirait
donc que le chaos qui a eu qui a eu lieu
à la fin ne peut en aucun cas être
attribuée à l'administration trump et
est ce qui s'est passé avant c'est
uniquement la responsabilité de dieu de
l'administration de biden et on se rend
bien compte 1 on a vu les l'airé des
sénateurs républicains dire vous nous
avez trahi à propos de 2,2 à anthony
blinken et anthony blinken pour dans
certains cas être proprement incapable
de répondre certains sénateurs
d'ailleurs lui disant je ne veux même
pas entendre votre réponse je voulais
juste vous dire ça donc voilà donc le
chaos et le sentiment d'humiliation et
le sentiment que l'armée l'amérique et a
pris une gifle of finalement face à la
face au monde et bien ça c'est quelque
chose qui embarrasse l'administration by
john qui a fait baisser la cote de
popularité du président parce que les
amériques a évidemment n'aime pas se
sentir humilié
quelques axes de défense un cas tenter
anthony blinken en a hérité d'une date
limite mais pas d'un plan de sortie
anthony blinken qui dit également que
l'effondrement des forces afghanes en
aussi peu de temps était je cite
imprévisible même d'après des
spécialistes américains les plus
pessimistes c'est ce qu'il dit
non ça je vous dis ça c'est pas vrai du
tout moi j'ai passé trois semaines en
afghanistan en juillet
donc je suis rendu dans le nez
territoire taliban g j'ai constaté
d'ailleurs que les talibans tout autour
de kaboul mener des attaques à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres du centre ville
de kaboul déjà en juillet je dirais que
la plupart des routes du pays était
totalement comment dangereuse et est
très est impraticable et les talibans il
procédait à des checkpoints et à dire
qu'ils avaient installé leur pouvoir il
avait commencé à gérer lors comment leur
a administré leur ronde progressivement
grignotant le pays ne se ne s'attaquait
pas aux villes et quand ils ont commencé
à s'attaquer aux villes elles sont
tombées les unes après les autres
pourquoi parce que les talibans déjà
négocié avec les gouverneurs la ville de
djalal abad il ya deux mois de
négociations entre les administrateurs
censé être pro gouvernemental censé dans
épaulé par les américains et qui
négocier avec les talibans ça c'est des
choses qu'on voit assez couramment en
afghanistan mais on ne peut pas me faire
croire que les américains n'étaient pas
au courant de ces négociations étant
donné que ça fait 20 ans qu'ils sont
dans le pays qui a un maillage des
services de renseignement et que je vous
dis encore les français semblaient plus
préparés à cette éventualité d'un d'un
art et d'une arrivée rapide des talibans
peut-être plus rapide que prévu que les
américains qui est finalement attendu au
dernier moment et on a vu la catastrophe
qui s'est produite